[Musique]
jenny dulys petit bonjour oui bonjour
merci de m'accueillir ce matin bonjour à
la martinique entière est
particulièrement pénalisé au pdl vous
êtes donc mr du morne rouge depuis 2008
vous allez conduire la liste montrouge
toujours du boot pour les élections de
2020 qu'est ce qui vous motive encore
bien vous savez vous soulignez que j'ai
été élu en 2008
c'est vrai que ça me fera ma troisième
mandature est donc ce qui me motive
c'est que je vous dis d'abord que je
suis né pour servir et je considère que
j'ai une mission envers les pnpp
d'où cette volonté de continuer le
travail commencé depuis 2008 vous savez
quand municipalité on ne peut jamais
arrêter comme cela c'est quoi votre
mission pour le pire
la mission s'est jamais mettre au
service des pme 24 heures sur 24 et
c'est ce que je fais depuis 2008 je le
faisais déjà avant poste 424 vous n'avez
pas de vie qu'on voulait on n'a pas de
vie vous avez des gens qui sont nés peau
servait quand on est né pour servir ya
pas de leurs alors vous êtes et vous
avez dit donc élu en 2008
mais vous avez est-il longtemps première
adjointe de pierre petit depuis 4989 1
vous avez été premier adjoint depuis un
petit avant de devenir maire et au mans
ne ronge on dit que 2020 pourrait être
votre dernier mandat que vous avez envie
de préparer la relève de passer la main
en 2000 après 2020 on ne peut pas dire
que c'est un dernier mandat on peut pas
prévoir six ans c'est long donc c'est
chemin faisant qu'on verra de toutes les
manières on ne peut pas non plus
attendre la fin de mandat pour préparer
quelqu'un il y a des gens qui se
préparent déjà à ce que vous prêtez vous
préparer déjà la relève ou certainement
puisque les personnes comme vous
composer une liste
on a fait pas comme ça au hasard vous
faites la liste avec des gens
d'engagement des gens qui comme vous
sans motiver pour servir une population
d'accord et dans quelle direction cette
relève pour et quelle direction traite
relève pourrait prendre
vous savez déjà à peu près vous avez
déjà une petite idée
on peut avoir des idées mais le moment
n'est pas venu de dévoiler les secrets
d'accord il n'y a que deux meilleurs de
mes rêves en martinique marie thérèse
casimir yeux et vous et pour les
élections de 2000 il fait une femme tête
de liste sur environ 120 candidats la
martinique est en retard nous sommes en
retard effectivement par rapport à la
guadeloupe et puis d'autres pays on va
pas comparer à la france hexagonale mais
déjà à côté de nous en guadeloupe depuis
bien longtemps les femmes occupaient les
postes de mire maintenant la martinique
commence à vouloir rattraper
nous pensons qu'à la fin des élections
de 2000 20 au soir du 25 mars
il y aura davantage de femmes jeudi par
je ne demande pas la moitié mais je
souhaite qu'il y ait davantage de femmes
que ce team blot concours ça ne s'est
pas encore dans les mentalités
c'est pas dans les mentalités et
n'allons pas critiquer nous sommes
vous savez bien que et tout quand un
politique a derrière lui une femme qui
fait le travail
une femme qui fait un travail dans
l'ombre donc il ya beaucoup de femmes en
capacité
encore faudrait-il que l'or mais accepte
qu'elle soit aussi candidate
alors si vous êtes élu quelles seront
les grandes orientations aux grandes
orientations qu est ce que vous allez
poursuivre nous allons donc poursuivre
le travail commencé depuis 2008 ou alors
si vous voulez depuis très longtemps
mais pour cette mandature nous avons des
projets qui nous tiennent à coeur
vous savez on parle souvent du
désenclavement des communes - le rouge
pourrait s'ouvrir vers l'aurait savez
que dans les années 60 il y avait déjà
un début de l'une d'une trace par savan
petit pour arriver à mon capot au lourd
et ça se faisait par le rsma
vous avez aussi par le corniaud thing we
y aller et puis bien sûr par la mental
par la montagne pelée on peut arriver à
gruyères on peut arriver a ajouté mme
bouillon en plus de desservir
saint-pierre donc autant d'ouvertures
pour ouvrir le monde rouge permettent au
moulin rouge de se dégager n'oubliez pas
que nous avons sur notre territoire
jazz est reine qui traverse
j'ai entendu parler d'un projet de deux
routes qui sortirait du morne rouge et
qui pourrait rallier fort de france
oui bon c'est toujours possible ça s'est
toujours passé n'ont détruit un peu la
montagne ont détruit soit par la trace
soit par les tourelles par la trace
ainsi que ça va très vite mais c'est
vrai que le monde rouge doit s'ouvrir je
vous disais tout à l'heure avec toutes
ces perspectives et surtout pour dégager
le beau pour éviter qu'il y ait trop de
voitures stationnées et permettre que
cela
la circulation sera fluide jenny dulys
petit je vous remercie
c'est moi merci à tous de m'avoir écouté